what up world it's your boy mc magic
debut with my new artist j-rocks right
here
on the bootleg kev show let's go
all right it's the bootleg cab podcast
special guest is here ladies and
gentlemen the legend himself my good
friend
mc magic thanks for having us welcome
it's a pleasure you brought a guest
you're a new artist i want you to
introduce her man i'd like to introduce
uh el centro's
princessa el centros princessa j rocks
nasty boy records artist brother now you
haven't signed an artist in a very long
time
that's right the last time you were
working with someone as i recall was mob
fam
fam yeah and that was nine years ago
eight years ago actually a couple of
years back i did i did work with mob fam
and we were trying to launch them but i
think the problem that we have with mob
fam we just couldn't find
their audience we couldn't find their
audience
and then uh and then uh i met this
little chicana girl from
uh from tucson name named selena called
her little lena
and we probably dropped about five six
videos and dropped a bunch of singles
that we just we couldn't get it to stick
we couldn't get a stick but then when i
met jay rocks
uh in may of last year it was like okay
this is the one
so i've been trying right it's just
you're not like gonna do it just to do
it you gotta find the right artist
yeah i gotta when i go behind something
i gotta feel it a hundred percent
brother
wow and then you she just put her album
you said that you guys
had a virtual release party and i mean
the numbers are going crazy
yes right the virtual release party was
the day before the album came out
obviously album came out on february
19th and we had it on the 18th
and uh you know we had allen eyes
hosting we had robbed the original
uh doing a painting of her in the house
all during the the
the performances little rob perform i
performed
she she did you know how many songs you
five five songs that night yeah about
four or five
yeah and it was just it was just a
beautiful thing matter of fact if you go
back and look at the album release party
you would say
this is the way of the future of
releasing albums
right and and i think you're right i
think obviously the pandemic has
not i mean it's been a lot of negatives
but i think the positives are
it has showed us new innovative ways to
connect with fans
and just more efficient ways
to do certain things it made the hustle
muscle stronger
it oh that's the realest [ __ ] i tell
everybody man if you let this pandemic
hit you and and you and and this
separated the real hustlers from the
fake ones man
because if if this [ __ ] did not put a
battery in your back
to get to it because i swear that's how
i felt i felt like
reminds me of a meme that uh that chewie
gomez put up
uh he said shout out to chewie yeah
shout out chewie gomez in the bay area
he said back in the days drug dealers
had houses cars expensive watches and a
lot of money
he said these days drug dealers ain't
got none of that sometimes they
even got drugs
nowadays the drug dealers aren't dealing
drugs anymore they're just scamming the
government for ppp
loans you know what i'm saying that's
crazy it's insane i thought it was
pretty funny
yeah no that's great um so uh
yeah first of all you grew up in mcmahon
you're 18 years old so you're very young
so magic was really in his prime you
probably were a baby
like well i'm trying to think magic when
did i get into radio this was like a
magic city era so what was that oh 405
06.
and magic city came out in 06. so yeah
you were like a
toddler running around you know what i
mean so how did you come up like
knowing about magic and listen to his
music um yeah cause my parents say
listen to a lot of that type of music so
i grew up listening to him and i
actually met him once before when i was
like seven or eight years old
at the lowrider show at uh my the local
fair
that we have an imperial yep and um i
met him there i i obviously he doesn't
remember but
i'm still trying to find the picture too
because i was like oh you still haven't
you haven't found the photo that'd be
that'd be a great photo to find i know
it wouldn't and
i'll repost it don't no please don't
no but it's funny because that day he he
signed a poster for me and i had it
forever forever for years and one time
my mom cleaned my room
and she threw it in the trash and i said
mom i was like why'd you throw it away
out and she was like cuz you never hang
it up or whatever and i was like but i
might need that one day
as a joke you know and it's crazy
because here we are years later
and now he's my best friend i don't have
the poster anymore wow
that's so your mom threw the poster away
yeah
but you know how many posters i gave out
i signed i gave as part of a package
uh i think that's one of the things that
helped me stay relevant
is always giving fans something to not
forget of course i remember every time
yeah you'd have to
you'd have your tent and posters
just everything yeah yeah for people who
are so so obviously
the podcaster has a very hardcore rap
following but you're like a legend where
i'm from
and your good friend if people don't
know mcmagick a lot of people who
are clicking on this and watching this
probably know who you are but for people
who don't know man you've been
uh kind of a pioneer in in the
latin rap world but just in general just
arizona
yes yes and you know i'm glad you said
that kev because
uh normally with the demographic that
you
mostly cater to yeah uh wouldn't even
take an interview by mc magic
you know even j rocks and so you made
the exception for us brother and i
appreciate that no of course man
of course his family um you actually the
dope thing about magic the people don't
know
he started off the way i started off
kind of differently
but had to swap me oh yeah hustling at
the hot to swap me you know that's where
i got my name was
bootlegging albums and um
yeah at the same swap meet that back in
the day magic was cutting
cutting custom tapes for people on the
spot yeah i mean and i was bootlegging
songs like you as well
so i would have the mixtapes i call the
mixtape yeah instead of bootlegs
i i had the mixtapes and then i would
record custom songs too so people could
buy my album a mixtape
and a custom song you know i'd knock
them down for 45 50 bucks
right so i mean the hustle must have got
to be strong 45.50
and you can still go get you a custom mc
magic song 100 bucks
200 baby uh where do you
f you know because i you know i think
that um i was
you know your era of what quote unquote
you know and i don't think you
necessarily are a chicano rapper because
you make love music
i think that's what people we just have
we just had this conversation you have
rap songs
but people love you for the love [ __ ]
that's really true that even the guys
tell me that
yeah that's not how many ladies i was
able to conquer with your music
and not in those exact words but you
feel the same yeah and so
i think um you know the era that you
know
i i want to call the glory days of that
genre when it was
the low rider shows and little rob
guys like yourself high power records
and just this whole entire
movement that was really like it was
nothing i haven't seen anything like it
since yeah well you know what
baby bash was cracking little rob was
cracking uh
frankie jay was cracking mc magic miami
writer song
amanda perez man depressed so that whole
era
we had a moment where we were we were
close to being pop music you know what
i'm saying
no for sure you had you guys had radio
success um
nationally but like where do you think
that like because i feel like there's
kind of an evolution of that that's
going on right now but what like
where do you see that the latin hip-hop
scene now
like as far as the mexican hip-hop scene
because i want to say the word latin
because that's
bad bunny you know you know latin is a
big word it covers a lot of a lot of
the mexican hip-hop scene but chicano
rap uh
mexican rap uh chicano hip-hop you know
we've been trying we've been trying to
stay relevant we've been trying to
continue to put out music like a lot of
people think
you know like sometimes i'll meet fans
where you been i haven't seen you
forever
but i've released songs at least a one
song a year
for the last whatever i know yeah you've
been working i've been working uh
simultaneously doing other things yeah
the records you put out with cuckoo a
couple years ago was fire
super fire yeah yeah the search record
that came out in 2019
uh and then in 2020 uh we we worked on
j-rock's album
obviously it's not mc magic album uh but
we just dropped it in 2021
so i steady been working and so has baby
bash
so has frankie uh so has little rob
little rob
and her have a single called uh i belong
to you
uh and that's her biggest single on the
album right now wow he hit a million a
million views with it
that's big man yeah do you like like
how crazy is it uh coming from el centro
california because that is a very small
market
it's super crazy um like growing up i
always didn't want to be a singer but it
just never seemed like a reality for me
just because like
where i come from right like it's always
people like in la or stuff like that i
would think you know
but now that i'm here it's just like
it's just it feels so fake you know it's
like unreal
um and a lot of people back home are
proud of me you know they're like
made out of value i feel like i i don't
consider myself like that i made it yet
but
to them you know because it's like not a
lot of people um
you know do make it out of the valley yo
what's crazy is like
you were saying you tried to make the
other girl from tucson pop right i
really did
so so like i feel like what she is
bringing to the table is
loki kind of missing i think it is i
think it is we're filling a void
uh you know and we're in town actually
to record with another little chick on a
girl named bella the rapper
oh dope yeah and so tomorrow we'll be in
the studio with her
but there is a movement and like i said
people are trying it's just about
you know striking that that that magic
in a bottle you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah song that really takes over i
mean because to this day
people that don't even know that i that
i did it can sing something about you
babe yeah it's crazy
you know what i'm saying yeah it's it's
pretty wild so
for you like how talk about the input of
the music right because you obviously
know how to make records she's young she
knows how to sing
were you writing songs already or like
i've been writing i've been writing real
music since i was 14 years old
um a lot of people not gonna lie like
there's some haters that they think like
he did everything for me and that all it
happened overnight and and stuff like
that and it's like no i've been singing
since i was seven and
i've been writing and i even tried to
learn how to produce my music since i
was 14 years old
um so mc magic met me three years into
like you know my whole
music journey and actually when he met
me i was like in the process of
writing a pop punk ep pop punk yeah
okay yeah she's very versatile bro yeah
a pop punk ep yeah and it was just to
have about like three or four songs
maybe and
that's what i was working on um when we
met at the time and
and i've always told them some magic
since like i could do anything any genre
you want me to i could i could do it
and i'll be the best at it too damn and
that's exactly what we did with the
album
like the album is not a genre it's not a
chicano rap record the one
the the one with little rob is right you
know she's got cumbias on the
she's got a selena cover oh [ __ ] um we
got pop records a record called psycho
and things like that so we tried we
tried
not to not to make a multi-genre album
we just were doing
what she loves you see i'm saying right
are you getting inspired by so many
different artists and songs i was like i
was like we got to make something like
this we got to make something like this
yeah who are your favorite artists
because you're obviously you're making a
pop pop punk song like wait
um okay well i have like that's that's
like not a good question because i have
too many but i'll try to like hit like
my favorite
like okay pop definitely eminem he's
like
the best like oh my god eminem yeah all
right
and that's that's why i told him to
magic today he was like when i got off
the car he said he liked my outfit i was
like guys because i'm trying to dress
like eminem
and just stand up show you she's a shady
outfit show the camera
i see she got the dickies the whole suit
on with the forces okay
no you don't have to you don't have to
well the real shade i'm kidding but
yeah so definitely eminem um
xxxtentacion
okay um um avenged sevenfold
oh [ __ ] all right she went there amy
wine
she's versatile oh man that's she said
avenged sevenfold amy winehouse eminem
and x
matter of fact that's about as versatile
as it gets i wanted to sing one of her
records today but i also wanted to do an
amy white house cover
okay just to give you guys a little
dynamic right yeah i like
like that's what i'm saying i like too
many artists like you know say all of
them but those are definitely um
definitely up there those are like my
top artist are you worried about getting
boxed in
as like a chicana artist no but even if
people do that i won't get mad because
it's like um
at least if we're gonna at least if
we're gonna have someone representing
like we're gonna have a chicano face if
it's me i have no problem with that like
right i'll be happy like i'll take it
but um my music will prove otherwise
like people can say like oh like she's
just that she kind of artist everybody
all they're gonna do is press play and
they'll be like oh no this is a lot of
there's a lot more here
yeah there really is there really is and
i'm gonna tell you what bootleg i met
her on
instagram live oh really i was talking
to the fans yeah like you do yeah
she came on and the first thing she said
is i want to sing for you so she's
saying one of my songs she's saying so
that can go left
it really can trust me i've been on that
ig live and i've been like yo fam listen
you got a job
cool keep that [ __ ] right
but the reason the reason that i was
really you know like
uh attracted to what she was because she
said no let me get my guitar
and then she was saying an original song
that her and her dad had already started
writing oh wow and i'm like
okay this little girl's got like she's
she's and i know she already had her own
spotify
that her name was already you know
verified on twitter right
you know and i'm surprised you just
started with asking her why she called
herself j rocks
yeah that is yeah there's there's yeah
that's an interesting name for a singer
yeah there's there's j-rock from tde
yeah what's the game break that down
please
okay so growing up okay so my dad he's a
real big boxing fan like
okay huge like that's his life and and
growing up he thought that i was gonna
be a boxer
so i used to do boxing for a part of my
life growing up and um he used to call
me j-rock because he said that would be
my box
her name is jaylene rock she says
at least you're a singer you could be a
j-rock as i said you just couldn't be a
rapper it'd be called james
j-rocks yeah so so growing up he would
call me j-rock but then when it was time
to pick an artist name i was like dad
what the like what should i call myself
like i can't do just j that's too simple
like what should we do right
and he's like what about um j-rock and i
was like there's already a rapper named
j-rock though like i can't
i can't just take that you know j-rock
so he was like how about j-rocks and i
was like
i was like what do you mean he's like
but spell it like this and then i was
like oh shoot because with the triple x
yeah because that's my way of paying
homage to x oh wow that's dope
yeah when x died that's when i really
like i've always been into music and
music has always been my life always
been in love with music but
when x died that was different that was
it like it hit something in my soul that
i just can't i can't explain let me ask
you something
when you're a female artist and there's
three x's at the end of your name have
you had like
people hit you with the other side of
that um not really
no because when you like you know you
know i think back in the day when i
would see like
artists spell their name with that [ __ ]
it's always something else going on
yeah yeah x-rated yeah yeah yeah so that
really is like a classification for
you know adult entertainment right right
i never thought about it because
uh you know because she was just like of
course of course of course
love triple x dental no i think that's
great to pay homage and
it's crazy because like i don't think
people understand like older people at
least
how much of a impact that dude had on
that whole generation of kids because my
son's the same way it's like
it's like they're tupac of course we
don't even think about it because
because when he was alive it's kind of
similar to biggie in the sense that
biggie only had one album out before he
died
x didn't have a lot of music out he
passed away and he made such an impact
on these kids
he really did uh and you know i'm not a
big ex fan
but she is and i think one thing is
really important about
letting the artist be who they are you
know uh because
uh me being who i am it caused me a lot
of
a lot of uh struggles and trying to
prove to people right
right i was good enough to be on a
playlist with lil wayne it's just
so much so much uh turmoil but i never
stopped being me and that's why it's
benefited me in the long run
hey interrupting the interview to tell
you about our good friends at odd socks
now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
ooh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssocksofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have underwear that's right
you can get your odd socks
underwear the boxer briefs are the best
underwear that you could ever fit on
your ass trust me when i tell you
these are chucky draws what you know
about top ramen underwear all right go
to oddssocksofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg kev at checkout and you'll save
20 percent off
of of your order underwear masks
slippers socks whatever you need they
got it oddsofficial.com keyword bootleg
cabinet check out save 20
you know i don't i i do have input but a
lot of like her name
uh the songs that she chooses when she
tells me i don't like that it's done
we're not what i'm gonna yeah because
you don't wanna fight you on things you
know
every day nah that's crazy yeah i think
i think
you know i think you you've uh you've
had a very unique perspective through
the business because you've been on
every side of it you used to you've done
the radio side you've done every side of
this [ __ ] i have done every side of it
from
you know from the swap meet hustle to
sitting in a room
with universal records you know
universal records was trying to sign me
and
kept throwing more money more money on
the table and i didn't feel it i walked
out of the room doug morris is in the
room said whatever it takes
wow i walked out i'm like i don't i
don't need this
was that was that um after yours
oh wow so that was that was that's that
was nasty boy
click this wow i was the only one doing
the negotiating in new york
how was um magic uh you know getting
through the uh reunion
with the envy riders i mean that was a
really uh special moment
it was fun it was fun shout out to those
guys who clearly uh
you know they were like i remember
seeing them dudes on stage and i was
like hey man at least i ain't the only
[ __ ] who's getting out of shape
out here
cause i was like you could tell them
guys they've been performing
no no they're both legends but i
remember just feeling i was like man at
least i'm not the only one
who's also just putting on the weight
from felix mean getting old
is part of getting fat of course man me
and you both buddy [ __ ]
man but nah but i mean i thought the
show was dope like
um would you guys ever even do an album
together
again or you i have a certain feeling
about going back to the mb riders thing
first of all like i don't like to go
backwards i like to go forward
right you know and this is fresh young
even even if this album is
doesn't blow we got a whole lot of time
to work no of course
you're just getting started and you're
already doing it she's already doing
numbers right already
yeah already we're already out of the
red oh that's beautiful
we're already out of the red that's hard
to get come on now yeah and so
anyway i have a feeling about going back
to try to recreate
that magic because it was an era it was
a beautiful music people love it to
death
and why mess with it it's fine the way
it is yeah you might you're right i
think a lot of times
maybe people [ __ ] up by going back and i
don't i don't want to do that
yeah because i created something
beautiful right and amazing
you know legendary for phoenix you know
for arizona yeah and i just like to
leave it like that
let's go on to the next have people try
to uh
sample any of your old [ __ ] flip it i've
had i've had a few people you know reach
out and and sample my stuff which is
cool
if you had like a younger doper artist
like a younger dope artist
rather that was like yo i want to remake
this song of yours
would you give him the blessing yeah
absolutely okay i got no problem with
that you know
the you know madonna gave us clearance
on one of the big first samples she ever
cleared
wow you know when we did a z side take a
little trip the remix of that
had a madonna sample on it it would go
everybody
and she cleared it she cleared the
sample bro so why would i be an [ __ ]
to somebody it just it
don't make sense you know that's and
then you get publishing and you get it
and you get it and you get a chunk
and we get you know the pockets a little
thicker so her project's out
yes are you working on new music for
yourself are you focusing on her always
working on new music
and i keep telling people my album's
coming but i think my bar is set too
high for myself
like in your opinion what is your best
body of work
my best body of work including
everything including nasty boy click and
be right is
all the magic see like what's your
what's your personal favorite
personal favorite is magic city the
album yeah we had a lot to prove when i
i think that you had a lot to prove and
you not only because
i remember at the time there was like
this we like
upstairs records was a thing and you
broke away and it was ugly
they were hating on us at radio and joe
had so much power
i remember that and i remember you came
you came with it though
yeah we did man as soon as as soon as
mikey fuentes started playing sexy lady
and he forced power 92 to play it
because that was at the
at latino vibe in phoenix yep and then
kkfr
they got on it and i remember [ __ ] i
[ __ ] that song was so
bruce st james said nope i'm gonna own
it and he played the f
bro cause i was when i was interning and
i felt like it played every
yeah it was i was so tired of that it
song it was number one
on on uh on sandra and sandra's sandra
pena yep
sandra yeah it was number one for two
months
on her top eight at eight that was an
error man
that look then that low rider show that
year which was the first lowrider show i
ever worked at the uh
stadium back when radio meant everything
you know but that low rider show was
special man yeah
you had that you had like a whole
[ __ ] row of
section and felt like we had it all the
line was so big bro
like yeah it was crazy that that that
was uh 2006 brother
2006 at the arizona state fairgrounds
yeah oh six times i brought the two
flags on stage yeah it's crazy because i
always tell people like if you've seen
mc magic
he got the same intro but it's impactful
it's great
it's welcome for magic city errors how
you come out with the flags and [ __ ]
it's it's dope brother it's it's become
it's become a staple for me you know
yeah so are you guys are i mean we i
talked about this off off the mic a bit
but
obviously live shows are coming back are
you guys gonna be doing so are you gonna
be taking her out on the road yeah
lost in love tour mcmagic little robin j
rocks
okay yeah already got a few dates i mean
if it's all it's already on sale in uh
in san diego in chicago
and uh and el paso but you know the
behind the scenes making sure the
tickets get on sale make sure the
heading is right on the table is it
harder for you to do live
like hard ticket shows at home because
you've done so much in phoenix
no you know what because i feel like you
were so accessible in phoenix for a long
time because
especially when you're on the radio
because people people could go to a
people could listen to you in the
morning or they could go to a remote and
meet you or
and that's the reason why me and big d
decided we're only going to do two shows
a year in phoenix
up until the pandemic that's all we did
we did
the arizona super show right and we did
the arizona state fair
that's it of course so for years that's
all i was doing
but it just seems like because i've been
there all my life seems like
i'm at every car wash yeah it's crazy
man
how's um you know it's it's was there
ever
any sort of discussion about like a
super group
between like like getting like magic and
yourself and
and maybe bash and rob and like maybe
just doing like a super group
album we've done the tour we've done
this i know i'm saying but
that idea had to have at least gotten
floated out there whether or not it
actually is ever going to happen
you know it's just three different
entities
it's three different also three
different vibes musically all three
as much as you guys have the same fans
musically you guys are
way on yeah magic is doing love songs
kind of like frankie j uh lil rob is
definitely neighborhood music and then
baby bash is doing the club [ __ ]
baby bash is doing bad [ __ ] yeah that's
crazy
i love it it comes together great for
concerts you know the live shows are
great
and now we're incorporating j-rocks to
be part of the shows and stuff so she
started to perform on stage we had a we
had a
once they opened it up in california we
had a physical album release party
and her hometown is sold out el centro
so you're kind of like the home down
hero huh
i guess so yeah yeah that's fire well
look go get her out what's her name her
album this is
princesa and your parents like do you
have like a is your like
you brought your dad here does he manage
you or my dad he's a daddy
he's a doubter oh okay earl woods over
there
i love freddie man me uh freddie and i
have become real close
uh working this project and he's such a
knowledgeable uh
straight-up dude he's not afraid to take
a risk and he's a boxing encyclopedia
oh wow yeah nice shout out to canelo who
just picked up that w
broke that man with right under his eye
yo that's great so he's a big boxing guy
yeah i think too like having having your
dad as your manager is like at least you
know you always have someone who's like
at the end of the day you could always
trust your your dad okay you know what i
mean yeah and he wants the best for his
little yeah he wants the best for his
little girl
but he also he's part of the reason why
she knows about eminem
she knows about all the chicano rap
right because he raised her with
with that music around him so it's kind
of it's kind of his project
not kinda it is his project he's taking
ownership of it too yeah as he should
yeah but he just wants his little girl
to shine and i want the same you know
well listen go get the album
and or you're gonna be on tour with this
guy soon he's gonna be on the side of
the stage while you're performing
switching the screens and [ __ ] and she
knows that we've done it already
yeah he's gonna have to what's up but
laughing the last time i saw your son
was running the merch booth
yeah my youngest
both of my youngest uh still work for me
and your son's a dope
videographer one yeah two of my sons are
doing videographers
uh editors filmers all of that uh daniel
and marco but marco my oldest son
now lives in uh ohio so i don't see him
as hot
but the creative the the creativity in
our home is just bananas you know wow
well listen
mc magic and j-rocks j-rocks yeah
j-rocks but before we go i brought you
some gifts bro okay what do we got cause
you know i came from the swap meet so i
always got to have something to sell
all right all right what are we selling
let's let's do a commercial so everyone
can go to
well i'm gonna start with my magic box
this is this is a bluetooth speaker uh
for my homie uh
bootleg cab same font as magic city of
course
of course got my official font there you
go oh
magic box i got a gif for you oh this is
great that is nice
put that on okay this this might live up
here this might be on the podcast all
times
yeah yeah i think it should be yeah it
should be oh this is dope
oh yeah yeah you know it's it's not a
huge use
nah but it's dope to be a personal a
personal uh thing that girls like
like doing their makeup of course they
could put it in children
in the bathroom because i said yeah you
feel me you sell makeup
you don't know that oh man i had no idea
this is this guy right here this
[ __ ] mc magic is selling
everything
you know i know i know you recently you
recently got married yes
you know what that means yeah yeah of
course come on i'm a married to a
mexican woman and i have a
half mexican child yeah these are the mc
magic this is what my wife will throw at
me when she's angry
oh yeah okay these are for the wife
oh what are you not selling oh i'm
selling it we got music
okay and i also brought some makeup too
this is this is so you could
you bring it bring it home to the wifey
and i should have just
this is amazing yeah i'd like to point
out that this is amazing
something about you baby okay
the mc magic makeup bro yeah
how's this stuff selling oh come on man
come on my brother what
come on my brother this guy's a beast
it's working that's called mamacita this
is a little compact mirror
i want you to see the names of my
palettes brother
i want you to see what's that what's
that palette called right there
let me see lost in love
wow right check it out sexy lady this is
for your girl brother
all right no no i'm hooking her up hold
on let's see what the sexy lady the sexy
lady palette
yo you ain't playing magic you ain't
playing
the hustle does not stop over here and
you know what it's so amazing doing
makeup for girls because
my music has always been celebrating the
beauty of girls of course
the wonder the wonderful that they are
pretty girl yeah of course come on now
come on man
you know magic is in his bag right here
i'm designing these myself bro
welcome to magic city you'll feel me
wow this guy hey listen any artist
watching this
step your [ __ ] hustle up because if
you ain't doing this [ __ ] i want to hear
from you
yeah because you know right here oh yeah
she'll love those
yeah so i just wanted to give you a few
gifts thank you man i'm i'm loving it
man my wife will love this stuff
and of course this will this will get
put to use yeah yeah a little bluetooth
what's the website that everyone can get
all your stuff at nastyboyrecords.com
you've been saying it on the songs for
years yes nastyboyrecords.com it ain't
changed
damn there it is perfect yeah yeah you
know we got j
rocks our newest addition to the team
and you know she's ready to do it
she's a little hip-hop head too bro i
mean she said her favorite rapper was m
m yes so i believe it yeah no doubt no
doubt
yeah that's i mean that's pretty
awesomely random 18 year old
18 year old girl from el centro and her
favorite rapper's m
m yeah yeah and she's gonna sing for you
today all right we're gonna make we're
gonna make it happen all right that's
gonna be on a different youtube video
so go watch that one after this one boom